foreign
[Music]
the purpose of this film is to show how
to record and code observations of
nursing personnel activities in
hospitals
the technique is described in recent
studies developed by the public health
service
the study method
has been published in the manual how to
study nursing activities in a patient
unit
other manuals how to study supervisor
activities in a hospital nursing service
and how to study the nursing service of
an outpatient department
describe adaptation
of this method of observation
the observer is the key figure in all
studies of nursing activities
she wears a white coat over her street
clothes
she does not wear a nurse's uniform or
cat
although she is one of the nurses
selected from among the nursing
personnel of the hospital
she is not dressed as a nurse so that
patients won't expect her to provide
care
the observer carries a pencil and a
clipboard
to which are attached a watch and
several blank observers record forms
here is the unit in which the
observations are to be made
and these are the people our observer
will study
we are going to demonstrate the work
sampling method of observation
we do not watch each member of the
nursing staff constantly but look to see
what she is doing during a selected
interval of time
in this study the interval is 15 minutes
the personnel who are to be observed
are tagged with cards which identify
them
according to their job title
rn for professional nurse
hn for head nurse and so on
when the unit employs more than one
person in each category
of nursing service
aides
practical nurses
professional nurses for example
the tags are numbered to help the
observer recognize
which individual she is observing
all members of the nursing service in
the study unit are tagged in this way
for the purpose of this film
our observer will locate and record
the activities of each staff member
once every 15 minutes
the head nurse
the professional nurse
in this study there are two
rn1
and rn2
the student nurse
the practical nurse
if more than one practical nurse is
employed on the unit they would be
tagged
pn1
pn2
and so on
then
the nursing aid is observed
the clerk
and any other personnel on the unit
employed by nursing service
the observer must find each person
assigned to nursing service
on the study unit
she must observe the activity being
performed at that time
then she records it
if there are more than 12 persons on
duty at any time during the study period
two observers will have to be assigned
four forms are needed for each hour of
observation
one form for every 15 minutes
here we see a simplified record
before the observation starts
the observer should fill in the headings
on all the forms she is going to use
begin with the name of the unit
then
the name of the observer
and the date
then
insert the time of day
when the observations are to be made
number the page
now list in column b
on each form
the code titles of the personnel to be
observed on this unit
the symbols
h n
r n
p n
s n
and so forth
are what we call the code titles for
each category of nursing personnel
now fill in
in column a
the exact time
when the study is to begin
remember
each member of the nursing staff must be
observed once
every 15 minutes
now we are ready to begin
the observer does not try to locate the
staff in the order listed on the forms
she observes the person nearest her
and records exactly what is happening
in column e on the form
the observer sees an aid wheeling a
patient down the hall
she asks the aide where she is going and
why
the aide replies i'm taking the patient
to x-ray
the observer immediately records the
activity
otherwise she might forget it
in the rush of each 15-minute
observation period
this activity is recorded in column e
as taking patient to x-ray
the activity observed
must be written clearly and concisely
so that any reader will know what
happened
to whom
and with whom
then it is coded according to areas
in column c
taking patient to x-ray
is an activity in the presence of a
patient
but it is not a treatment
therefore it is recorded in column c
as code 12
which you will recall from your list of
code references
is
other direct activities
the activity is now recorded
according to the level
of skill
which is required to perform it
accompanying a patient to x-ray
or to other departments of the hospital
does not usually require nursing aid
skills
so
enter
m e s
messenger
in column d
here is an example of another activity
observed
the head nurse is giving a student nurse
instructions
regarding the care of a specific patient
write this activity
in column e
then
in column c
area
code the activity as 13
because it is exchange of information
about a patient
next
insert in column d
the level of the activity being
performed
the level is hn
as this activity of the head nurse
is at her own level of responsibility
now let's assume we're recording the
same activity
but in relation to the student nurse
who is receiving the instruction
the activity is filled in
in column e
receiving assignment from head nurse
then
insert sn
in column d
as this is a proper level of activity
for a student nurse
in column c area
write 13 again
as this is also an exchange of
information about the patient
our next example
shows a clerk making out medicine cards
from the order book write this activity
in column e
in column c
insert
14
indirect care
now code the activity by level
cl
for clerk
copying information or other data
involves clerical skills
it is not in nursing activity
the observer next sees the practical
nurse
going into the corridor
and asks her where she is going
the practical nurse replies
i'm going to ask the head nurse how to
prepare an oxygen tent
for use on the unit
this activity will be filled in
in column e
then it is to be coded in column c
this code area is 21
in-service development
this is the chosen code because the
observer understands that what the
practical nurse is about to do
is something which will improve her
skill
in caring for patients
the level
which is pn
is then inserted in column d
the practical nurse
is functioning at her level
when receiving instructions from the
head nurse
here is our last example
the observer sees rn1
carrying a treatment tray as she leaves
the patient
she has just changed addressing
the activity is part of the care given
so it is recorded in column e
as changing patients dressing
it is coded by area in column c
as 11 giving care
encoded by level
rn
in column d
now let's review
the important steps to remember are
make only one observation
of each person
every 15 minutes
don't try to locate the staff in the
order listed
but just as you happen to find them
first
write the activity clearly and concisely
then code it by area
then by level
the observer now waits until the next
15-minute interval is to begin
before making any additional observation
because her 15 minutes aren't up she
relaxes
[Music]
um
[Music]
this is the second part of a two-part
film demonstrating observation
techniques described in the division of
nursing resources manual how to study
nursing activities in a patient unit
[Music]
in part one we observed the activities
of various kinds of nursing personnel
we recorded our observations on the
observer's record sheet
entering the activity clearly and
concisely
coding it by area
and by level
and making only one observation
of each person
every 15 minutes
we will continue to use the same
observation method
and the same 15-minute observation
period in this film
however this time we will talk about
activities which the observer may find
confusing or difficult to code
because what the person observed is
doing is not evident
several persons are observed
simultaneously
the activity observed apparently is not
at the level of the person performing it
one person is performing two activities
at the same time
or perhaps the activity involves a
telephone conversation with the observer
hearing only part of the discussion
let us first take a situation where the
purpose of an activity by a member of
the nursing staff is not obvious
to record the activity as walking down
hall would not really identify the
activity
what the observer must learn is intent
why this activity is being performed
what are you doing the observer asks
coming from pharmacy the nurse might
reply
this answer is still inadequate
why did you go to pharmacy to get unit
drugs
the observer now has enough information
to record the activity
she enters 30 after rn in the area
column because the activity is
housekeeping
and even though the person observed is a
nurse carrying medicines
the level of the activity is messenger
a student nurse walking down the hall
volunteers i'm answering the light in
407.
this activity is indirect care
the observer codes it as area 14.
and under level enters sn
what are you doing the observer asks the
practical nurse
i'm waiting for the diet trays to arrive
from the kitchen
this again is indirect care
it is a dietary level
a student nurse tells the observer
i'm waiting to demonstrate that i know
how to do an irrigation
this is coded area 22 student education
the level is sn
the head nurse seems to be preoccupied
the observer asks what are you thinking
about
the head nurse answers that she is
worried about a patient's reaction to
medication
this is indirect care
and since reaction to medicine is
properly a head nurse concern it is
coded hn in the level column
suppose the head nurse had answered
i was thinking about a movie i saw last
night
this would be a strictly personal
thought having no bearing on the work
situation and would be so coded
often several people are observed
simultaneously
the observer records each individual's
activity separately
here the rn is assigning duties to a
student nurse and a nursing aide
the observer records the rn's activity
as exchange of information about patient
the student nurse asks should i give the
treatment before or after bathing the
patient
the observer records this as asking how
to assure best results from treatment
she codes it area 22
because it contributes to the
educational development of a student
the nursing aide has been listening to
this exchange of information
her activity is coded area 13
at n a level
when an activity is not at the level of
the person performing it the observer
must learn the reason behind it the head
nurse is arranging flowers at a
patient's bedside
as she leaves the patient's room the
observer questions her
i hate to see flowers just stuck in a
vase
in this instance the activity is
housekeeping
even though it was performed by a head
nurse
had she replied i wanted to see how the
patient was doing the intention would
have been entirely different
the level then would be hn
whenever two activities are being
performed at the same time by one person
the observer must decide which is more
important
an rn is passing diet trades
she pauses when a patient asks her about
his diet
explaining dietary needs to a patient is
an activity that outranks the passing of
trays
in such a situation the observer records
the higher level activity
and instead of writing d for dietary
under level she writes rn
as this activity is not a specific
treatment it is coded in area 12.
if two activities being performed by the
same person are at equal level
as when an rn prepares a piece of
equipment for a treatment and at the
same time demonstrates this procedure to
a student nurse
the observer lists both activities
she leaves the area column blank until
she can ask the study director which
activity is more important for the
purpose of this study
telephone conversations present a
special problem because the observer
cannot hear everything that is said
the observer waits until the call has
been completed and then asks her
questions
she must learn the purpose and content
of the conversation and to whom the
nurse was speaking
only then can she code the area and
level of the activity accurately
many other situations are confusing or
difficult to code meal time is an
example
if a full-time nurse takes more time
than authorized for meals
the excess time is recorded personal
meal time for part-time employees is
always coded personal
sometimes a nurse cannot be located
within the observation period
the observer simply waits until the next
time she sees her then asks her what she
was doing and enters the activity
accordingly
you have seen examples of typical
problems which you as an observer will
encounter
other situations will undoubtedly arise
their solution
[Music]
and the success of your nursing activity
study
will depend upon your ability to
function as a keen and interested
observer
you